de tête tout le monde le sait ne bouge
pas non mais ça vient tout le monde a
rouge et serge si je remets le chapeau
bougeait pas
franchement thierry ça te dirai pas
lequel pétanque voile et je suis maso
combat parce qu'il faut être maso pour
battre à chaque fois pareil la bronca
même avec une mauresque et des boules ça
passe très bien
il faut aimer être soumis pour mettre ça
voyez vraiment assez le chapeau de la
soumission à l'est c'est parce qu'on
venait à quoi fait bien fait au mieux ça
va mais cheveux bien donc un thème prise
de tête êtes prête là est ce que vous
êtes c'est pas des questions compliquées
c'est juste votre avis est ce que vous
êtes favorable au divorce
ben oui bien sûr voyant d'azur banon
mais si la question se pose si déjà la
question se pose c'est que tu n'as pas
aller très bien donc il dévore tout quoi
bon vous êtes favorable au divorce
je suis pas favorable au divorce si les
gens déjà ils ont décidé de se marier et
ben s'impose ouais voilà
voici déjà exposé la question c'est
est-ce que vous êtes favorable à la
fidélité dans le couple
bah ça c'est pareil moi forcément si on
me demande
bah oui pour moi oui pour les autres ça
les regarde érection toute manière là
quand je dis tout ça non mais ça veut
rien dire sa patte à chaque fois
différent non mais c'est vous qui nous
intéresse est oui non mais d'accord mais
même moi
voilà mon mari je dessine depuis dix ans
à quelqu'un et que je les aime vraiment
mais quand même temps ben il faut jamais
savoir quoi que m mais c'est bien
présente en tout cas moi c'est
l'interview prise de tête ça c'est
galère gens sont pas déçus chez eux et
moi est ce que vous êtes favorable à
l'adoption d'enfants par dés couples
homosexuels dans les corridas pourquoi
dans des corridas l'adoption les enfants
groupe et les sujets un peu brûlant on
s'en va gagner 20 minutes cette manière
que ce soit des homosexuels pas des
coups aussi des compléments et vous
anthony camou chaque que des couples
homosexuels puissent adapter des enfants
ça me choque pas écoutez c'est difficile
d'y répondre - personne personne au
départ comme ça je suis contre si on
doit dire pour ou contre je dirais
contre après il ya un grand débat là
dessus est ce qu'un enfant simply
malheureux en maison de est enfin là
d'un souhait ce qui sera plus malheureux
avec des parents là on le sait pas mais
c'est après il ya tout un débat mais
c'est vrai que sur le principe vous êtes
contre évidemment tout le monde désire
et même chose il vaut mieux avoir des
parents homosexuels sympa que des
parents hétérosexuels quoique c'est un
débat alors isild l'avortement d'être
pour ou contre l'euthanasie notation
vous tenez dans une centrale nucléaire
en gros toujours les sujets hockey la
peine de mort j'imagine que vous êtes
contre la peine de mort comme nous tous
mais est-ce que vous êtes contre la
peine de mort pour les assassins
d'enfants
ben en fait par exemple
si c'est mon enfant qu il est la peine
de mort où qu'il aille en prison pour
moi c'est pas été aussi je veux tu mois
après que ça à quelqu'un de têtu
bon j'aurais envie de tuer moi mais vous
feriez cdc défend les circonstances mais
sans doute pas c'est un enfant qui a tué
notre en soir mais là ya pas de problème
dans tant que ce soit d'autre au fond et
c'est bien ce qu'il faut fratelli prise
de sept mois gebert à chaud